[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que nos
lleva a líbano específicamente a beirut
su capital que el 4 de agosto de 2020
fue el escenario de una explosión que
mató a más de 200 personas y dejó a
otras seis mil heridas primero llegaron
las impresionantes imágenes que le
dieron la vuelta al mundo en las redes
sociales en pocos minutos luego vino la
estupefacción de los habitantes ante la
magnitud de los daños finalmente llegó
la ira de todo un país por una
catástrofe que pudo haberse evitado el
origen de la explosión en el puerto de
beirut fueron 2.700 toneladas de nitrato
de amonio un compuesto utilizado como
fertilizante pero también es un agente
explosivo muy potente llevaba más de
seis años almacenado allí sin
precauciones esta tragedia es vista por
ohl libaneses como un símbolo de la
terrible crisis política social y
económica en la que se encuentra el país
la investigación judicial sobre la
explosión aún no ha concluido y líbano
se ha hunde aún más en la inflación el
desempleo la crisis alimentaria la
escases de combustible la mitad de la
población ahora vive en la pobreza
nuestros reporteros volvieron al lugar
de la catástrofe
en una ciudad azotada y que aún no ha
curado sus heridas
[Aplausos]
no es eso
buenos balances las mejoras como se
llame
davis vale el doble
notificación
regalos un tiempo escolar
y acciones
[Aplausos]
la dinámica social paralizada
es algo grande
[Aplausos]
no
[Música]
a ver
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bien
y por primera vez al lugar donde suelo
trabajar a la terraza donde estaba
sentado unos segundos antes de la
explosión hace nueve días cuando acaba
de terminar el que se convirtió en el
capítulo 50 de este libro y escribía las
primeras líneas del siguiente no había
vuelto a esta mesa desde que empecé a
escribir no por superstición sino porque
hace mucho calor
excepto que hoy necesitaba volver a
conectar con el hilo roto del tiempo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
esta sangre es la sangre de mi papá
y por esta sangre tengo sed de justicia
por esta sangre que viene exijo
respuestas y lucharé por ella
extraño a mi papá extraño verlo sentado
aquí conmigo pienso en cuando
caminábamos juntos cada segundo que pase
con él por eso ya no tengo miedo nada me
detendrá ni a mí ni a ninguna de las
familias víctimas nada nos detendrá
después de lo que hemos pasado no quiero
palabras bonitas
simplemente exijo que se haga justicia
por lo que pasó yo yo porque si se hace
justicia de una vez por todas líbano
cambiará viva no se convertirá en un
estado donde por fin se aplique la ley
under law
me paso el día corriendo de banco en
banco cambiando dólares a libras según
la tasa oficial luego comparándola con
tasa del banco luego con la tasa de los
cambistas luego con la tasa del mercado
negro haciendo cálculos planeando gastar
la mitad en cheques la mitad en efectivo
antes de confundirme y mandarlo todo al
[__] mi esposa me dijo el otro día que
si toda la población utilizará mejor
solo una parte de la energía que está
utilizando para intentar salir de la
trampa en la que se encuentra por la
quiebra del estado y de los bancos
seríamos capaces de darle la vuelta al
país en 48 horas
entonces la farmacia está en huelga y al
frente hay una fila de autos de 500
metros que esperan la estación de
servicio
esto es el gran síntoma si no hay
gasolina la gente hace fila y la
farmacia está en huelga en fin todo está
dicho
en aquel momento cuando ocurrió nadie
podría imaginar que eso podría durar un
año más porque pensábamos esta es la
gota que colmó el vaso esto es lo que
acabará con todo y no acabó con nada
otro poste
y luego nos dijimos pero al fin y al
cabo porque iba a acabar con algo esta
gente vive en autarquía una especie de
fortaleza están en una fortaleza que
defienden insultando al pueblo
paradójicamente nos tienen a su merced
mientras ellos mismos están en la
fortaleza de su poder y nada los moverá
de ese lugar excepto un movimiento
extremadamente violento es un movimiento
que se llevará todo y a todos nosotros
con él
esa es la estación la antigua estación
si es la antigua estación de tren y
después la convirtieron en depósito de
autobuses de servicio público pero ya no
hay servicio público así que ya no hay
nada
pero ese también es el problema la
compañía ferroviaria todavía existe
lleva 40 años pagando sueldos tiene un
director un gerente aunque no haya
trenes este es también el síndrome del
cliente eligen que obviamente genera
gastos inútiles que son comparables a la
corrupción
en todos estos barrios que quedaron
destruidos eran también todos los
estudios de artistas de todos los
diseñadores creadores arquitectos de
este barrio desapareció que era un
barrio que aún sobrevivían crisis era
una especie de vitalidad creativa y la
explosión acabó con él en 562 conocía
como si se hubiera centrado en el punto
que seguía vivo la fama así de rápido
acabó con él
beirut es simplemente una ciudad que no
quiere morir durante 30 años o incluso
50 años hemos ido acumulando traumas
sucesivos y no hemos resuelto ninguno
están ahí uno tras otro amontonándose
nosotros viviendo entre ellos o
resolvimos nada reprimimos y cuando uno
reprime no logra ser resiliente para el
contrario tenemos algo dentro de
nosotros que quiere resurgir con eso
pero ya no somos capaces de soportar
nada
sé lo que estoy llorando acabo de
comprender que el duelo de este hijo el
sufrimiento que siente cada día por
haber visto morir a su madre es otro
duelo que yo también vivo desde hace
varios meses un duelo que no quería
reconocer que aún ahora me cuesta
admitir pero que es real que se impone y
me abruma me cuesta decirlo escribirlo
pero tiene que ver con este país que
agoniza que se marchita tiene que ver
con el luto de todo lo que hemos hecho
con el esplendor de nuestras vidas
pasadas con lo que hemos soñado tiene
que ver con el miedo a la degradación
que se avecina a la pérdida de nuestra
dignidad
digno
[Música]
de que
tenía
luna
[Música]
ante esto qué es
ah
hoy
[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo
[Música]
es una tienda que vende frutas y
verduras los precios son realmente
exorbitantes
el kilo de almendras cuesta 12.000
libras
está pasando
ya no compro carne el avión está a 120
mil libras del kilo cuando hace poco
estaba a 20 mil libras
medio kilo y otro medio kilo
era mucho más barato durante la guerra
civil este ser
todo era más barato los dos la hora
cuando uno se va a dormir algún dólar
vale 15.000 libras y cuando uno se
despierta vale 18 mil libras a veces
incluso más es terrible es realmente
terrible
como un perrillo ritmo cómo podemos
vivir dígame cómo podemos vivir te
advierto no hay gasolina ni electricidad
ni pan sólo el sol sigue siendo gratuito
porque su control
francia está presente en líbano desde
hace mucho tiempo y sé que las personas
de esa época pueden pedir la
nacionalidad francesa
yo nací en 1936 así pudiera tener esta
nacionalidad les estaría muy agradecida
porque no estoy tranquila pero nada está
garantizado para mí en a mi edad ya no
trabajo ya no tengo rentabilidad y yo en
spas de laron te invidente no tengo nada
que me permita vivir el tiempo que me da
vivir
me encontré en cuatro patas con sangre y
polvo blanco en mis manos luminaris
sangraba cuando tenía la carencia
inventada y estaba gritando y haciendo
señas hacia la casa destruida y gemir
pero estaba atrapado bajo el bloque de
vidrio como todos los muebles de la
habitación fueron succionados y una mesa
salió volando y le aplastó el tórax los
meseros entraron gritando que la
explosión le rompió una costilla ella
estaba sentada ensangrentada en las
escaleras pero yo no sabía qué hacer
para ayudarla acabaron en el suelo una
al lado de la otra pero ninguna de las
dos pudo volver a levantarse en pedazos
de ventana se cayó y le rompió el hombro
y le arrancó la oreja y también esto fue
levantado y lanzado contra el televisor
lo encontramos acurrucada en un sillón y
ella creía que estaba en el sofá voló y
cayó sobre ella camine como un sonámbulo
por la calle antes de darme cuenta de
que todos estaban heridos a mi alrededor
le perdimos el rastro y terminamos
encontrando lo en el hospital de banes
encontraron abrir la puerta al auto pero
se dieron cuenta de que ya estaba muerto
sus pulmones estallaron todo se derrumbó
no quedaba nada lo encontraron muerto
dos horas
este dibujo es todo lo que queda de mi
papá
basurto
durante toda nuestra vida no hicimos
nada malo que nos ocupamos de nuestros
asuntos el eonia y su deseada
lo más importante para él era darnos los
medios para estudiar para que pudiéramos
vivir sin mayoría de nadie
espero que esté en el paraíso y que sepa
lo que estamos haciendo por el agua que
sepan que estamos luchando por él
[Música]
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a beirut recuerde que
si quiere ver este y otros contenidos en
español puede visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom hasta pronto
y
[Música]